the Trump administration announced this
afternoon it is reversing an Obama era
policy that encouraged colleges to
consider race during the college
admissions process of correspondent
Garrett Tenny reports tonight on what
brought them to this decision today the
Justice Department announced it's
getting rid of Obama era guidelines
intended to promote diversity by using
race in college admissions decisions the
guidelines from 2011 and 2016 laid out
legal recommendations for schools
looking to use affirmative action
Trump's DOJ argues that the Obama
administration's guidance isn't legally
sound and goes beyond Supreme Court
precedent on that issue we're sending
the guidelines doesn't change the law
but supporters of the move hope it
pushes colleges to change it will be one
more step in discouraging universities
and colleges from using race and
ethnicity as a criteria for admissions
that should not be happening in America
in the year of 2018 Attorney General
Jeff Sessions has now rescinded dozens
of guidance documents issued by the
Obama administration after launching a
review last year
DOJ determined a lot of the Obama era
policies were inconsistent with the
Constitution saying today the executive
branch cannot circumvent Congress or the
courts by creating guidance that goes
beyond the law and in some instances
stays on the books for decades but
critics suggests this reversal is a
politically motivated attack on
affirmative action all across the
country we're seeing a coordinated
series of attacks on race-conscious
policies in the higher ed context it
sends the wrong message to
administrators and college presidents
all across our country that are working
hard to ensure diversity on their
campuses the Supreme Court last held
that affirmative action was
constitutional in 2016 the deciding vote
in that case was Justice Anthony Kennedy
who in his opinion left the door open to
future legal challenges and with his
retirement it's just another example of
how a successor is expected to have a
major impact on the court for years to
come John Garrett any thank you